last time we left Mexico it was in an
ideological struggle between the
conservatives which favored a very
centralized administration that retained
many aspects of the former colony with
most favouring a reinstatement of the
european-style monarchy and the Liberals
which favoured curbing the power of the
church and the military and most wanting
an establishment of a more US a style
republic and this ideological divide
wouldn't really go away for the next
century or more since it'll beat his
death Mexico is highly unstable going
from being an empire to an ill-conceived
Republic to them being attacked by Spain
trying to reconquer it - then another
ill-conceived Republic - then losing a
war with Texas and the USA while
switching to a third ill-conceived
Republic oh well this guy Antonio Lopez
de Santa Ana and military leader
president dictator kind of controlled
things to various degrees during this
period oh and while all of this was
happening a bunch of conservative and
liberal rebellions occurred as well
helping to increase the natural chaos of
the era all this combined and more that
we don't have time to talk about meant
that Mexico is in a deep state of [ __ ] I
mean poop and it is this state of
affairs in the year of 1854 that we
start our journey as I have mentioned
before since the first Mexican Empire
the Mexican politics were largely
dictated by one person Santa Ana he is a
complicated character to say the least
he was a prominent military leader a
president and a dictator sometimes all
at once sometimes one at a time
sometimes he called politics boring and
left on a military campaign while
leaving someone else in charge sometimes
he left completely only to later come
back it was a game of hats to him
nonetheless even though it can't be said
he completely controlled Mexico during
the entire time since the dissolution of
the Empire he was so prominent in
Mexican politics during this time that
many historians just call it the age of
Santa Ana as all major events in Mexican
history during this era involved him in
one way or another he wasn't really
liked by the Conservatives or the
Liberals as his reforms were very
staunchly centralist not giving either
side what they wanted he mainly managed
to stay in power because of public
support political maneuvering between
the two faction
and backing from the military but in
1854 he was finally overthrown by the
Liberals who quickly started
implementing their laws known as la
reforma culminating in the 1857 new
constitution which by the way if you're
keeping count is the fourth
ill-conceived republic nonetheless the
Conservatives weren't happy to say the
least and with this new 1857 liberal
Constitution something had to be done so
they launched a coup d'etat taking
control of Mexico City and rolling back
the liberal reforms the Liberals
retreated to Veracruz and called the
Conservative government illegitimate and
so the rest of Mexico had to choose
whether to support the Liberal
government in Veracruz or the
conservative government in Mexico City
and with that the civil war known as the
reformed war started initially the
conservative forces had an upper hand
already controlling some of the liberal
states and having a much better equipped
and trained army however USA decided it
would be better for them if Mexico was
controlled by the Republic lining
liberals rather than the monarchy
leaning conservatives and so they
started to support the Liberals who in
the end thanks in part to the support
managed to win in 1860 appointing benito
juarez as the new mexican president in
1861 but at this point as you would
imagine Mexico was devastated its
infrastructure in ruins immensely in
debts the economy barely holding
together and conservative guerrillas
still patrolling the countryside trying
to fight the Liberal government wherever
they can
Benito Juarez had no choice but to
default on the Mexican debt which was
mainly owned by the British French and
the Spanish obviously these three
countries weren't happy with this and so
decided to invade Mexico to force the
Liberal government to pay its debt but
not all of these countries had the same
plan Napoleon the third King of France
was hoping to install a French favoring
monarchy in Mexico as to have an ally in
the new world and when Mexico defaulted
on its debt it gave Napoleon the perfect
causes belli to make this happen plus
USA was in the middle of a civil war
meaning they couldn't interfere with
Napoleon's plan when the
English and Spanish found out about the
ulterior plans of the French they
promptly withdrew their forces as they
didn't want to support a French coup now
alone the French army was defeated on
May the 5th at the Battle of Puebla by
Ignacio Zaragoza this Mexican victory is
celebrated today as Cinco DeMayo which
if you ask me is kind of a random battle
to have a whole holiday around yes the
Mexicans won against a much better
trained and equipped French army all
while being outnumbered two to one but
in the grand scheme of things the battle
doesn't really change much the French
army just retreated waited for
reinforcements and then defeated the
Mexican army anyways yes there are some
interesting aspects of the battle
applied to it retroactively Lee but
during that time it was just another
battle of many in Mexican history but I
digress
Napoleon now controlled Mexico well kind
of the Liberal government of Benito
Juarez relocated to Chihuahua with the
country's Treasury hoping to continue
the fight against the French which they
did but very unsuccessfully Napoleon
also gained support from the Mexican
conservatives whom ever since their loss
in the reform war wanted to get their
power back so with Mexico now largely in
the French hands and with the help of
the Conservatives the second Mexican
Empire was declared non going after that
a suitable European monarch to take the
new throne was searched for kind of
having a deja boo' here a suitable
monarch was quickly found austrian-born
Ferdinand Maximilian Joseph from the
house of habsburg-lorraine the younger
brother of Franz Josef yes that Franz
Josef but unlike his brother Maximilian
was a true renaissance man believing in
the many ideas that came from the
Enlightenment by age 17 he was taking 55
different classes ranging from fencing
to history and engineering he also spoke
seven to eight languages including
Spanish and everything Maximilian ever
did he was trying to surpass his older
brother to show everyone that even
though not in line for the throne he
would be a better ruler than Franz Josef
in the end he was largely ignored and
held several royal
positions within the Austrian Kingdom
before being asked by Napoleon the third
if he wanted the Mexican throne
Maximilian didn't want to take the crown
at first saying he will only take it if
the Mexican people vote in favor of him
Napoleon along with the Mexican
conservatives obliged and staged a
dubious vote which surprisingly turned
out overwhelmingly in the favor of
Maximilian unbeknownst to the fabricated
vote Maximilian promptly left for Mexico
with his wife Charlotte of Belgium
hoping to once and for all prove to
everyone that he will be a great monarch
Maximilian arrived to Mexico to a very
cold welcome there wasn't even anyone in
Veracruz to meet him he just kind of
stepped off the boat and waited turns
out their conservative attache that was
supposed to meet Maximilian and Veracruz
confused the time of his arrival and so
came much later nonetheless Maximilian
was taken to Mexico City where he chose
Chapultepec castle as a seat of power
but this is where the entire situation
started to become much more clearer to
Maximilian first he found out that he
wasn't actually elected by the Mexican
people and many of them didn't want him
here second he realized he was only in
power because of the French military in
Mexico that was keeping him in power
without it the Liberal government of
Huaraz would come back third turns out
that Mexico was financially in a
disaster this combined with the fact
that a large portion of the Treasury was
taken by the Liberals and that it wasn't
him but the French government who
controlled the Mexican Finance Ministry
meant that even though Maximilian was
the Emperor he did not have control over
the country's coffers or the military
keeping him in power but that didn't
dissuade the young Emperor who had
something to prove he quickly got to
work reforming the Mexican Empire
according to the ideas of the
Enlightenment which by the way were very
similar to the ideas that the Liberals
implemented at the start of the reform
war just a couple of years back
Maximilian abolished a large haciendas
monopolies in Mexico restricted working
hours banned child labor canceled all
peasants dead under 10 pesos and banned
all the selling and reselling of
independent Mexican peasants now
peons who up until now we're more like
slaves he enacted many more other
liberal reforms but we don't have time
to talk about all of them naturally all
these liberal reforms started to anger
the Conservatives who brought Maximilian
here to get rid of the liberal reforms
not to pass them
however maximillian's wife known in
Mexico as Carlota threw lavish Austrian
style galas and parties to keep the
aristocrats at least somewhat occupied
Plus in their conservative Minds having
a liberal monarch is still better than a
liberal government Maximilian also
brought many Austrian engineers to help
build up the Mexican infrastructure and
mainly rebuild Mexico City in the style
of the European capital cities for
example today's famous paseo de la
reforma was built by Maximilian suddenly
the tide started to change many liberals
seeing Maximilian's reforms start to
take up administrative jobs within
Maximilian's government thinking maybe
having this emperor isn't that bad the
peasants also started to turn to
Maximilian side mainly the indios class
who saw having an emperor a much better
option than being controlled by majority
mestizo / tree oil the bir government
and overall even the people who didn't
want a monarchy started to become much
less vocal about it as everyone was sick
of fighting at this point and if peace
meant having an Austrian monarch so be
it
Maximilian even tried to endear himself
to the Mexican people by walking around
the capital with no guards or entourage
wearing a sombrero and a Mexican chato
just chatting with the people and seeing
how today was going he even offered who
is a pardon and a prime ministerial
position in his new government
what is however declined he didn't fight
Santa Ana and the reform war just to now
work under a foreign monarch and that is
where the troubles for Maximilian start
piling on the Liberals were almost
stomped out by the French army but then
the u.s. Civil War ended USA now no
longer preoccupied decided it was time
to intervene the reasons for the
intervention were mainly that the US
didn't support the Liberals in the
form Wars just to see them now loose
power and also because all of this was a
European intervention in the Americas
which under the u.s. Monroe Doctrine was
a no-go which seems kind of hypocritical
but I digress President Andrew Johnson
couldn't get the Congress to agree on an
intervention plan so he just relocated a
lot of US Army to the Mexican border and
then just had them lose their weapons
and supply somewhere in that area the
Mexican liberals now with the US support
could finally go on the offensive and
started to win a bunch of battles and
retake some land Maximilian was now
forced to enact a black decree which
made anyone forming any armed bands to
be imprisoned and executed within 24
hours this did slow down the liberals
but also angered many other people who
are appalled by all the killing
sometimes even of innocent people who
happen to have guns on them so many
people started to support the Liberals
again while this was happening USA
exerted a lot of diplomatic pressure on
France urging them to leave at once this
combined with a looming franco-prussian
war back in Europe meant that Napoleon
had no choice but to withdraw all of his
troops from Mexico without the French
army the Mexican Empire would surely
fall and Napoleon urged Maximilian to
leave the country but Maximilian every
de nieve
Emperor was convinced by his
conservative advisors that a solid
defense can be mustered up against the
Liberals even without the French however
unbeknownst to Maximilian the
Conservatives didn't have much power
anymore ever since their defeat in the
reform war and this proposed defense was
just a pipe dream as a last-ditch effort
Maximilian himself went on to lead his
troops into battle and when it became
obvious that the Liberals will win he
allegedly hoped for a lucky bullet that
would kill him in battle fighting for
his country but it never came and
eventually he was captured and sentenced
to death a day before the execution
Maximilian was offered a chance to
escape but he refused as as Mexican
generals who were ordered to be executed
with him
make it and he wouldn't leave them
behind also escaping would mean shaving
his beard which along with the escape
itself would taint his proud Habsburg
heritage if caught then so he will stay
and face the firing squad as an emperor
his last words before a firing squad
were in flawless Spanish I forgive
everyone and I ask everyone to forgive
me may my blood which is about to be
shed before the good of the country Viva
Mexico
we've ally independencia
[Music]
Maximillian wasn't a perfect monarch he
was naive easily swayed by other people
and even though goal-oriented
he was very indecisive on how to get to
those goals but with his liberal ideas
and openness to hear out his advisers
with his care for all people regardless
of class and his passion to improve the
living standards for all Mexicans he was
in a way the perfect monarch for Mexico
and ironically while pursuing their goal
to stabilize the country
the Liberals may have squandered the
best chance for peace and stability
Mexico had in a long time or maybe not
maybe us would invade or friends would
fully take over who knows however I will
end with this statement after the
reinstatement of the republican
government who aris thought about
releasing a list of all the liberals
that asked for or gotten a job within
the Maximillian administration to which
Sebastiaan laid off a prominent liberal
himself replied if you publish that list
there will no longer be a liberal party
that is where this video ends please do
read the description for so much more
information that I was unable to cram
into this already pretty long video
information like the fact that there are
several contradicting sources on what
the actual last words of Maximilian
we're so if you want to know what
Maximilian may have said check out the
description also please if you can do
you support me on patreon the editing
and research for my videos takes a very
long time and this combined with the
fact that often times I have to cancel
the sponsor spots for my videos
including this one because the way they
want to implement them would ruin the
entire flow of the videos means that I
have yet to make a single dollar of
profit on my channel therefore any
support is appreciated as always my name
is ELISA and stick around for history